شكرًا لك،
لوفيتون هو أرخبيل يقع في
شمال غرب النرويج، تتمتع الجزر بتاريخ
فايكنغ فخور حيث
توفر البحار الغنية بالمغذيات هنا
مصدرًا غذائيًا وفيرًا
في الأيام الخوالي، كان الناس يعيشون
في جميع الجزر الصغيرة حيثما
يمكن أن يناسبوا منزلًا أو  أو مثل
مقصورة الصيادين وأقرب ما
يمكن من مناطق الصيد لأن
معظم الصيادين في
الأيام الخوالي كانوا يضطرون إلى الخروج،
فأنا أتوجه على متن أحد
أقدم قوارب الصيد في الجزيرة لإلقاء نظرة على
أكبر صناعة في لوفتون  كان لدينا سمك
الحدوق وبالطبع لدينا أيضًا الكثير
من سمك الهلبوت ولكن الشيء
المعروف قانونيًا به هو قطعة خبز [
موسيقى]
اليوم لدينا ما يقرب من
25000 شخص يعيشون في لوفوتين، ثلثهم
يعملون في صناعة صيد الأسماك
مع تزايد أعدادهم
نمت سمعة سياحة الجمال الطبيعي الهائلة
في جزر لوفتون في السنوات الأخيرة
حيث يتدفق الزوار لرؤية
الحياة البرية المذهلة مثل ويلز
ونسور البحر والأضواء الشمالية في
الربيع والخريف والشمس على مدار 24 ساعة في
أشهر الصيف.  واحدة
من أكثر تجارب الجولف الفريدة
على هذا الكوكب وكنت محظوظًا بما فيه الكفاية
لتجربة ذلك بنفسي
[موسيقى]
الشريحة لا تصدق، هكذا هو الحال
في الصيف هنا
لدينا ضوء الشمس لمدة 24 ساعة لمدة
شهرين، لذا فهي أيام رائعة جدًا
مثل  هذا لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى النوم، عليك
البقاء مستيقظًا ولعب الجولف، يا له من
منظر
هنا، نحن أرض شمس منتصف الليل
وقفنا على نقطة الإنطلاق الأولى وهو
منتصف الليل بالضبط، كما تعلم بالضبط، نعم،
تبدأ القصة حقًا بفكرة
صديق  كان والدي يعرف هذه الأرض وكان
مسافرًا إلى اسكتلندا
ورأى أوجه التشابه بين هذه المناظر
الطبيعية وملاعب الجولف في
اسكتلندا، هكذا بدأ الأمر
بملعب جولف صغير تم افتتاحه في عام
98 ثم كان في السادس  الثقوب
فقط لإثبات أنه كان من الممكن
مع المناخ
الجميل الذي
يضغط علي الآن وبعد ذلك الآن
أخيرًا حصلنا على
بعض التمويل بعد بضع سنوات ثم
قمنا ببناء 18 حفرة مناسبة والفكرة
كما هو الحال دائمًا كان لدينا
الشعار منذ  في البداية أردنا
إنشاء ملعب الجولف الأكثر روعة
في العالم
يا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية